Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still blazing a trail
for those who take their fate
into their own hands.
And tonight, baseball legend
and business titan
Alex Rodriguez
returns to the Tank.
Sometimes,
you have to understand
when the opportunity
of a lifetime is hitting you.
You guys are the world's
worst businesspeople,
or you don't need us.
Stop the madness.
No.
What am I eating here?
Sand?
Ohh, wah.
Geez.
I feel like I've been
an entrepreneur my whole life.
Why would you
want to invest with me?
‐Ouch!
‐I literally lost everything.
Oh, my God.
Where's all the money going?
Oh, boy.
[ Grunts ]
For 2.5%, you won't be
able to get him on the phone.
This would be
the dream team.
♪♪
‐[ Grunts ]
‐Ooh!
‐Yeah!
‐Yes.
‐Whoa!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a more convenient version
of a workout staple.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
We are Joe and Megan Johnson.
And we're from
East Lansing, Michigan.
We're seeking $250,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company,
Vade Nutrition.
♪♪
Sharks, working out
and going to the gym
is a part of Joe's
everyday life.
[ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
And afterwards,
he always opens up
a fresh tub
of protein powder...
[ Both exhale deeply ]
...only to realize he can't
find the scooper anywhere.
[ Groans ]
[ Laughter ]
And then when
he finally finds it,
now he always has to worry
about measuring
and scooping
without making a mess.
[ Laughter ]
This is definitely
not convenient.
And if he wants to take
his protein on the go,
he usually has to worry
about measuring it
into a little
plastic baggie
and then praying that it doesn't
bust open in his gym bag.
Stop the madness!
And that's when...
Pow!
...it hit us!
Dissolvable protein scoops,
baby!
That's right. This is a full
serving of protein powder
wrapped in a food‐grade,
edible film
that dissolves instantly
when shaken or blended in water,
milk,
or your favorite drink.
It's as easy as toss it in,
shake it up...
♪♪
...and pow!
You've got great protein shake,
ready to drink.
♪♪
[ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, we have created
the perfect protein
for the on‐the‐go lifestyle
because our product eliminates
all of the mess, hassle,
and excess
environmental waste.
So, Sharks...
‐Wow!
Who's flipping ready
to make a deal with us?
‐Wow.
‐That's impressive.
We have samples for you guys
to try out for yourself.
‐Awesome. Yeah.
‐Yeah, come on. Bring it.
‐Yeah, yeah, yeah.
‐Can we jump like that
when we're done?
[ Laughter ]
I want whatever
you had for breakfast.
Yeah, right?
All right, so we got
our little sample pack here.
It has chocolate and vanilla.
Works for me.
And you can go pick
whatever one you want.
‐Awesome.
‐Toss it in, shake it up.
‐Thanks, Joe.
‐There you go.
‐You're welcome.
‐Awesome.
‐Thank you.
‐You're welcome.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you very much.
‐You're welcome.
Greiner:
I like that the chocolate's
the same calories
as the vanilla.
‐Yes.
‐Never happens.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
Right.
Guys, what is the actual,
uh, package
that is wrapping
the protein powder made out of?
'Cause I'm gonna drink that,
too, when it dissolves.
It's made of 100% food‐grade
ingredients.
The main ingredient is used
to coat vitamins and pills,
and all the rest
are food‐binding agents.
This ‐‐ This ‐‐ This ‐‐
It looks like plastic.
It does look like plastic,
but it's totally edible, safe.
Shake it up, and you'll see
the film dissolves instantly.
‐You usually put a little ice?
‐Yeah, you can put ‐‐
You can put ice in it.
You can do ice.
A lot of people make them
with smoothies.
You can use milk, water,
some people put
the vanilla in some juice.
See, Mark knows how to shake it.
[ Laughs ]
What's nice is no sugar.
Yep, zero sugar.
Yes, absolutely.
How many calories in this?
90 calories in a serving.
I don't drink protein powders,
so educate me a little bit.
Is 90 calories on par
with typical protein powders?
It's very lean.
It's actually ‐‐
Yes, very lean.
So, our protein is 100%
whey isolate,
one of the leanest proteins
there are on the market.
There's only 2 carbs,
1 gram of fat, and 0 sugar.
Do they all taste this bad?
We've actually been told
that we have one of
the best‐tasting
protein powders.
‐I love it.
‐This is relative.
‐It's all relative.
‐I love it.
Yeah, everyone
has different tastes.
This great.
I love it. I've never really ‐‐
I never took protein...
Yes.
...before we started this.
Oh, my God. I might become,
like, a protein ‐‐
How much protein
in each serving?
20 grams.
20 grams of protein
per serving.
Can you guys tell us a little
bit about your background?
I went to school
at Michigan State.
Um, I got my degree
in finance there.
And during that time,
I wrestled.
And it was in college
that I met Megan,
who has also been
an athlete her whole life.
I was a gymnast
most of my life,
and we met at a summer camp
in Colorado
for college athletes.
Shortly after that,
I moved to Michigan
to start our life together,
get married,
and we have
a 2‐year‐old little boy.
All right. How much you selling?
Who's manufacturing?
What does it cost?
What are your gross margins?
Give us all of that.
Yep, absolutely.
So, we only started selling
product in July of 2017.
What we've been doing
is testing the market
because it's a completely
different product
than anything
this industry has seen.
And so up from ‐‐
Is it different only
because it's a different
delivery system, in a packet?
Absolutely, yep.
Yep.
That's your point
of difference.
Both: Yes.
The biggest innovation in ‐‐
really, in any type
of food right now
is convenient packaging
mechanisms, especially ‐‐
Do you have a patent
on that execution?
Patent pending.
Yes.
Cuban:
What's unique about
what you're doing
that makes it protectable?
It's a utility patent
on any consumable powder
that's wrapped entirely
by another consumable container.
Greiner: Really?
Megan: Yep.
Both of which are meant
to be consumed
at the exact same time
after being dissolved
in a water‐based liquid.
How's the pricing work?
If I'm somebody
who usually buys
the big gallon jar,
am I paying a significant
premium to do it
in small packs like this?
No, you're actually not.
And so, with a whey isolate,
the price is usually
between $1.20 and $2 a serving,
and we're
about $1.50 a serving.
What are your revenues
annually?
We've done $80,000.
$30,000 of that has come
in the past month.
Was any of that
Kickstarter?
None of that was Kickstarter.
No, it was not.
Okay, so where are you
selling through?
Online on our website,
as well as Amazon,
and then some other
online retailers.
We went to a fitness expo
to launch the product.
We were ready to, you know,
get some online orders,
maybe even ship
some product to the expo.
We had put about $50,000
towards the powder,
and then they sent
the protein powder
to get all packaged,
and it was wrong.
They had flavored it
incorrectly,
they refused to give us
our money back,
and this was our launch,
so it was really ‐‐
Welcome to being
an entrepreneur.
Poo‐poo happens, doesn't it?
Yeah, it was ‐‐ Yeah, it does.
[ Chuckles ]
Okay, so the majority of costs
for the whole industry
are marketing
and customer acquisition.
Yep, absolutely.
Because the margins
are crazy high, like 82%, 85%,
but they spend half
of their income marketing.
What are you gonna do
to get customers?
So, one of the really,
really cool things
that we're extremely excited
about is social media
because we haven't been
paying for social media,
but over a quarter
of our traffic to our website
has been from social media
because
people love to grab these.
To show it off.
The fitness Instagram
and the fitness industry is...
So you're gonna stay online
and try and acquire customers,
getting the buzz,
blogs, everything else?
Both: Yeah.
Because to get the shelf space
in the supplement aisle...
Yeah.
...whether ‐‐
whether it's in a drug store
or whether it's in
a nutritional retailer,
that's nearly impossible.
They don't give up shelf space.
‐Yeah, but that's
not your home run.
‐Yeah.
‐Right.
‐People aren't walking
into a drug store.
Right.
Right, your ‐‐
your home run comes
from licensing more
than anything else and
expanding it to new products.
Correct.
Both: Mm‐hmm. Yeah.
You know, because this ‐‐
this is where
you're testing it, right?
Yeah.
This is your
proof of concept.
Mm‐hmm.
It's everything else that you're
gonna make a lot of money off.
Right.
Corcoran: I have a question.
The only money you've made
is $60,000, did you say?
$80,000.
We've made $80,000.
We had a lot of ‐‐
Doesn't strike me
like a lot of money at all
for the time
you've been a business.
Yeah, it ‐‐ it absolutely ‐‐
Mm‐hmm.
So, we spent $300,000
on inventory...
Cuban: Ooh.
...and a lot of that has ‐‐
has gone away because of...
We have minimums that
we have to, you know, order.
Is that because of
the problems you had?
It's because of the problems
we had, yeah.
Yeah.
So some of it got burned.
It's tough, you know,
but we've gotten this far.
You know,
leading up to the January
when we really started
making sales, there was times
when it was like, "We might
have to shut this down."
Cuban: Okay, so, where you guys
are at, when you ‐‐
when you're grinding and
your back is against the wall,
you take the path of
least resistance to cash, right?
Yep.
Mm‐hmm.
And so on ‐‐ on one hand,
you have a patent...
Mm‐hmm.
...and that's your kind ‐‐
that's your hammer, right?
Yeah.
You're getting ready to use.
Your hammer is more important
than everything else
right now, right?
Yeah.
So I'm gonna
make you an offer.
Okay.
Right, and I think
where I can really
deliver value
is to keep you from making
these mistakes, right...
Yeah, absolutely.
...because everything
you're looking at
is spend some cash
to make some cash.
So I'd need more than 10%,
so what I'll do is
I'll offer you $350,000 for 20%.
What do you guys think?
Yeah.
That's a good offer.
I love ‐‐ I love that offer.
So is that a yes?
You want to hear what I think?
I'd like to...
Are we able to hear
from the other Sharks, please?
I might not be here, guys.
I ‐‐ I see the value.
But I'm not gonna guarantee
I'll be here.
♪♪
So, when you first came in,
I'm like, "Protein powder?"
[ Chuckles ]
And then I went from
completely neutral to,
"Wow, this is pretty cool."
Um, I love the delivery system,
and I think everything
Mark said,
I think he's right about.
I think it's great,
but I also think
that at the point of purchase,
there's a lot of things that
you could do to that packaging
to make someone really get it.
Um, I‐I'm sitting here with
my scales, like, kind of going,
"Do I make an offer?
Don't I?
It's tipping."
‐Yes.
Lori, you're thinking, so
that ‐‐ that may take a while.
So let me ‐‐ let me, um...
[ Laughter ]
Um, so ‐‐ so,
here's my offer.
So, this ‐‐ this business
is right in my wheelhouse.
Yeah.
I mean, between my sports
background,
the gyms that we own,
we have access
to over a thousand gyms.
We just bought a company called
Ice Shaker here last season.
Mm‐hmm.
Yeah.
And it's up over 500%.
I did that with Mark.
Now, I would offer you $700,000
for 40% if Mark and I
can go in together
and blow this up just like
we've b‐blown Ice Shaker up.
♪♪
‐I would do that.
‐You have both of us.
That's a heck of an offer.
Do you want to
think about that?
Yeah, yeah.
♪♪
You got to either come back
to us or answer us right now.
There's...
Okay. What do you think ‐‐
Would ‐‐ Would you guys be
willing to do it for 25%?
Not $700,000, no.
No.
Okay.
That's a huge amount of money.
‐You guys ‐‐
‐$700,000 for 25%?
This would be ‐‐
This would be
the dream team, right?
I know.
‐Like, we would ‐‐ we would.
‐Wow.
‐Well, grab it.
‐So you got to make a decision.
W‐We could do
less money for 25%.
I want the $700,000.
[ Indistinct whispering ]
♪♪
You got a deal.
All right.
Thank you guys so much.
Greiner: That's great, guys.
‐That's awesome, congrats.
‐This is amazing.
‐Come here. Congratulations.
‐Thank you so much.
Thank you,
appreciate it.
Congratulations.
Thanks, Mark.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, everyone.
‐Partner.
‐Yes!
‐We're gonna have some fun.
‐So nice to meet you.
‐We're gonna blow this up.
‐Folks back there.
We'll get it going right away.
‐Yes.
‐This is amazing.
‐We do this in our sleep.
‐Thank you guys so much!
‐Thanks, guys.
‐Appreciate it, congrats.
‐Take care.
Yeah.
We got a deal.
I couldn't even...
I can't believe it
right now.
Came in looking for $250,000,
and we got $700,000.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't believe it.
Megan:
We started with nothing,
and we had this dream
to get on "Shark Tank"...
Yes!
...and pitch our business
to the Sharks
and just this huge goal
that we wanted to reach
with our company,
and now we've done it, and
so this is literally shocking.
I can't believe it,
and it's amazing.
It means the world to us.
We got a deal!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next in the Tank is a way
to keep your valuables
safe and secure.
♪♪
Cranny: Hello, Sharks.
My name's Jeff Cranny.
I'm seeking $200,000
for a 20% equity
in my company, Lockstraps.
Sharks, theft can happen
to anyone anywhere at any time.
Maybe you're into desert sports,
like dirt bikes, quads, or UTVs.
Or maybe you're more into
the water‐sports kind of thing.
Big or small,
Lockstraps locks it all.
They have a stainless steel
cable embedded inside the strap
with two durable
combination‐locking carabiners
on both ends of the straps,
making them
almost impossible to cut.
Sharks, we have
a saying around here.
Lockstraps are kind of
like jock straps.
They help protect your junk.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
ARod, you look pretty strong.
Why don't you come up here
and try cutting one
of our Lockstraps.
All right.
So we're gonna start with
a traditional chain, right?
These are ‐‐ You've see them
in the back of trucks
locking up equipment
and things like that.
Yep.
This is the number‐one tool
that people use, right?
It's called bolt cutters.
All right, let's see
what happens.
♪♪
‐[ Grunts ]
‐Ooh!
How hard was that?
Alex is pretty strong.
Yeah.
Look at that.
So this is a traditional‐style
cable lock.
Go ahead.
‐Let's do it.
Okay. Nice and big,
nice and big, all in.
‐Kaboom.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐2 for 2.
Let's see how you do
on the Lockstrap.
Go ahead. Do it any way
you want to do it.
♪♪
Come on. Get it done.
Get it done. Come on.
[ Grunts ]
Come on! Get it done!
It's not ‐‐ it's not going!
Get it done!
Come on, baby. Come on.
Oh, my gosh.
Seriously, so now
what does that feel like?
Really?
Yeah.
You know what?
It's like it's giving,
and I'm not allowed to kind of
get my teeth in there.
I was just, like...
‐It's almost like rubbery to it?
‐Is it slipping between?
So you're saying
you struck out?
Yeah, well,
I'm 2 for 3 now.
It's pretty good.
That's pretty good.
‐All right, thanks.
‐Nice job.
‐Can we see the, um...
‐Can you hand us a sample?
...the strap that he...
Cranny: Yeah, actually,
I have samples for you guys.
Cuban: Great.
♪♪
O'Leary:
Why can't he cut through this?
'Cause it's much thinner
than the other steel cable.
The cable cutters are designed
to cut steel, okay?
This has steel and cloth ‐‐
two different forms.
Is this proprietary, putting
this cloth around a steel cable?
Someone owns a patent with
putting steel inside a strap.
That's not new.
Right.
Somebody owns a patent on
a locking‐combination carabiner.
Got it.
You don't have a specific ‐‐
I put it all together
and patented
the whole thing together.
Did you get one?
I got a design patent.
Okay.
A design patent.
I got a design patent
and a trademark, yes.
Let's talk about,
how many have you sold?
So this is the fun part,
right?
Uh‐oh.
Step one ‐‐
Yeah, here comes "Uh‐oh."
Here's the "Uh‐oh."
Okay, so?
We did about $135,000 in sales
in the first year.
Things were looking great,
we were going into
our second year,
we were already at $175,000,
and Home Depot
found interest in it,
but we didn't have
the type of money to do
a Home Depot purchase order,
so I partnered with a company
so that we could fill
the purchase order.
Equity partner?
No, no equity partner.
‐Who?
‐What kind of partner?
‐Oh, so you just financed it.
‐I own 100% of the business,
yeah.
How big was the order?
Uh, $1.5 million.
Yes.
‐Whoa.
‐Good for you.
Okay, go on.
What happens?
Okay. So I ‐‐
My factory wasn't big enough
to make the straps fast enough
to meet their orders,
so I allowed the company
that I went with
to make the straps for me.
We launched, we went out
on Home Depot's shelves,
but they got carried away.
They made them too fast.
And you tie your motorcycle
down just like that...
and they would slip.
‐Oh, boy.
‐Oh, my God.
So they all came back.
They all came back.
I made the teeth inside
this piece roll the strap
so the harder it would pull,
the more it would dig
into the strap.
When they redesigned it, they
decided to make the teeth flat.
Who redesigned it?
I‐In China,
the factory in China.
So you went
$1.9 million ‐‐
Because I didn't do
the purchase order, they did,
they went in the hole, yeah.
Wait, Home Depot or the person
you partnered with?
The middle man.
The person I partnered with,
yes.
So you were still involved,
or did you just step away
completely and just say,
"Send me my commission check"?
I just waited for
my royalty checks to come,
and then I started getting ‐‐
So you left it to them
completely, and they screwed up.
O'Leary:
Who cares about this?
How many got sold, actually,
before they got recalled?
I don't have that number because
it's their ‐‐ their number,
and we shook hands
and kind of went our own ways,
but we could still work
in the future.
Maybe ‐‐ Maybe what we learned
there, and we don't know it
'cause we don't have the data,
is, actually,
this product wasn't
gonna sell well anyway.
Cuban: Well, let's see
where we are, right?
So you've made these ‐‐
or somebody ‐‐
Or are these
the bad ones?
Uh, well, those don't have
the sliding clasp on it,
so those ones are okay.
There's ‐‐ This is the piece
that failed here.
Okay, you have a product
that you've made.
And right now, what do you
have in the market?
Right now, what we have
in the market
is the single carabiner
by itself.
Okay, so how much of these
did you sell?
How much have
I sold since when?
Since anytime,
'cause these aren't defective.
Oh, from Home Depot?
Yeah.
I don't have that number,
'cause they still have the ‐‐
they still have that
on the P. O. and all that.
Are you still partners
with those people?
Wait a second.
Aren't you trying to get ‐‐
This is like "Who's on First?
No, he's on third."
Yes, it is.
"Third's on second.
Third's playing second."
Don't you get an accounting
of what they sold?
"I Don't Know is on third."
Don't you
have that data?
I don't have that data.
Why not?
Because I knew
they were bad.
But, Jeff, are you selling it
now in Home Depot?
Not the bad product.
‐This one. This isn't bad.
‐Yes. Yes. Those are ‐‐
How well are they selling?
Yeah, those are still
being sold at Home Depot.
How are they selling?
What they did is, as you know,
they bring the price down
from what it was.
But how well
are they selling?
♪♪
They're not selling well,
and I believe
it's because of the bad ‐‐
And you're still getting
a royalty check
even though it's a small check?
Yes.
Look,
is this product a dog?
In other words, there's
nothing wrong with this.
There's nothing slipping.
It's in stores.
Nobody's buying it.
♪♪
Yes or no?
Yeah.
I would say yes.
You know what?
Jeff, my money's on first,
but he's on third.
I'm out. Good luck.
Thank you.
Good luck, though, Jeff.
I understand. I understand.
O'Leary: Look, I can't get
any data out of you.
Horrible presentation.
I'm out.
It concerns me that
you left your product,
and now you want us to come
back in with your product again.
It's not a very appetizing
story.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
All right, thank you.
Jeff, I can relate
with your story because,
you know, I played 23 years
in the major leagues.
Yes.
I'm fifth all‐time
in the history
of the game in strikeouts.
Mm‐hmm.
That means I have a PhD
at failing.
At failing.
But I also have a ‐‐
a master's at getting back up.
That's what
I'm trying to do.
But what I was hoping, when you
get a second bite at the apple,
you have a clear story
and a clear path,
and I still do not hear
that from you.
♪♪
I'm out.
Sorry to hear you go.
Greiner: So, I've never seen
an entrepreneur
that creates a product,
any product,
where they aren't completely
in love with it.
Their hands
are all over it.
They know every single thing
about it.
Even if you said
to that company,
"Put the money up.
Take over,"
the true spirit
of an entrepreneur
that's created their baby is,
"Let me see that sample.
Let me know exactly
what's going on.
I want to see
the packaging."
They want their hands
in every single bit of it.
Mm‐hmm.
And you just ‐‐ you let it go...
I‐I ‐‐
...and you didn't watch it
like it was your baby.
I am willing,
if you are willing,
to do a deal where
it becomes your baby.
♪♪
It pains me, but I'm out.
Good luck, buddy.
All right, thank you very much
for your time.
Really appreciate it.
Pleasure.
At the end of the day, you know,
I pick myself up,
get back on my feet,
get my company
back up on my feet,
and get rocking and rolling.
It's ‐‐ It's my only choice
I have.
All right, he comes back
and he's willing to make
the exact same
mistake again.
She says to him
you want ‐‐
she wants somebody
involved, active,
and he's like,
"I'll let you take over."
Yeah.
He's ready to cut that baby's
cord right then and there.
Bottom line is, there's so much
competition of lower prices,
why can't we just
say the truth sometimes?
"Arf, arf!"
♪♪
Hey, remember these silicones?
Well, they did $5 million
in sales!
Say what?!
I heard $5 million!
That's right, and it's because
I swam with the Sharks,
and I was bitten
by the warmest of them all.
♪♪
All:
We love you, "Shark Tank"!
Happy 10th!
Lee: [ Screams ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up are entrepreneurs
who believe they have a simple
solution to a universal problem.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Adam Callinan.
And I'm Matt Campbell.
We're cousins, best friends,
and the founders of BottleKeeper
based out of
El Segundo, California.
We're seeking
a $1 million investment
in exchange for 5%
of our company.
‐Wow!
‐Hello!
There is an epidemic
that has been plaguing the world
for centuries,
maybe even decades.
[ Chuckles ]
It won't stop,
and with global warming,
it's only getting worse.
This epidemic is, of course,
warm beer.
[ Chuckles ]
But there's no need to fret,
because we have
just the solution.
It was on a warm
but fateful summer day
that I was trying to enjoy
a beer from a red party cup,
and it was hot in minutes,
and just terrible.
And then it hit me.
Why can't I put a beer bottle
inside of one of those
stainless steel bottles
that are used
to keep water cold?
So I did just that,
and BottleKeeper was born.
‐One, two, three.
‐Reveal!
[ Laughs ]
BottleKeeper is an innovative
stainless steel bottle
that's insulated
with neoprene
so you can take
your cold beer bottle,
insert it,
lock on the base,
use this fancy‐schmancy
bottle opener
that's built into the top,
noting that the inside
also seals that inner bottle,
and enjoy.
‐Wow.
‐That's cool.
Now, which of you
cold‐beer‐loving Sharks
are gonna help us take a stand
against the warm‐beer epidemic
that has been plaguing
the world for centuries?
But first, let's loosen you
Sharks up with some beers.
‐Done. Let's go.
‐Smart man.
‐Yeah, cold!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Good.
‐Blue one for you.
‐Thank you, sir.
‐Black one for you.
Thank you.
I like the opener.
We talked about
the cold function
that BottleKeeper adds, but what
we didn't talk about is the fact
that that bottle really helps
to protect that inner bottle
so when you're at the pool
and you drop your glass beer,
it doesn't explode
all over your feet.
So we created a little demo.
We're gonna have one of you
cold‐beer‐loving Sharks
come up here and throw this hard
ball at that lineup of loaded
BottleKeepers,
and today we're in luck
because we happen
to have 14‐time
All Star, World Series
Champion in the house.
I know. I know.
‐Ohh, wah.
Come right back
and give it a wing.
Drill 'em.
‐Just hit 'em.
‐Perfect.
‐Wow.
‐Dead center.
‐See, not bad.
‐You did win a World Series.
Here you go, Alex.
You win your carnival prize.
‐You can't do better
than dead center.
‐Wow.
With a "Warm Beer Hater"
T‐shirt.
My ‐‐ My ‐‐ My daughters
would love this.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you. I like that.
That is not what I expected you
to give him.
So, now we, uh...
and, we are ‐‐
Yeah, we're good.
Oh, that's cool.
Okay, so let's talk
about $1 million for 5%,
impugning a $20 million
valuation.
‐Yes.
‐Yeah.
Now, that's very aggressive,
even on "Shark Tank,"
and that's why I'm so excited
to hear about your sales.
Sure.
We have done over
$1 million in sales...
in the last 10 days.
‐10 days?
‐No.
And $2 million
in the last 30 days,
and over $20 million
in the last three years.
Wait, reel it back.
Say it again slower.
What?
We've done over $1 million
in the last 10 days,
and over $20 million in
the last three years.
No way.
Yes, way.
Either you guys are the world's
worst businesspeople
or you don't need us,
so why are you here?
This is our first time
building a business
like this,
scaling things.
Our challenge
is that we've ‐‐
we've taken no outside
investment.
We've bootstrapped
everything ourselves.
We were bottlenecking
the company.
We really felt like we
could have grown a lot faster
if there was more
than just the two of us.
So what are your margins?
So our gross margin's 90%.
‐90%.
‐Yes. Yes.
‐90%?
Our average net income
is about 10%.
So, uh ‐‐
Because we're spending
a lot of money in ‐‐
in marketing, right?
We have the capacity to grow
a lot faster than we are.
We have ‐‐
Wait, I don't understand,
though.
I don't see where
all of a sudden
you would start
to have a problem,
unless you ‐‐ you don't
have money, you need money.
‐So what do you sell it for?
‐So what's the problem?
So, to answer your question,
we sell it for $34.99.
The problem is that we need
an influx of capital.
We're putting everything
that comes
out of net
back into the company,
but we have over 3,000 U. S.
retail stores
on a wait list
to purchase it.
What's the cost
to make it?
Yeah, about $3.50.
Cuban: So right now
you're only online
and you want to
go to retail?
Yeah.
We're completely
direct‐to‐consumer.
15% of our sales
is via Amazon,
and we're only really on Amazon
due to knock‐offs.
Do you have a patent?
We have multiple patents.
Utility?
Yeah, we have two patents
that have been ‐‐
Yes.
Rodriguez: Wait, wait.
I just want to take
a step back here.
Just really basic terms here.
The last 12 months, how much
have you made top line,
what is net,
net in your pocket?
We've grossed $9 million.
We've netted $400,000.
Where's all the money going?
IP enforcement.
We did have a very strategic
but expensive IP defense.
How expensive?
We sent about half a million
that came out of ‐‐
Okay.
Yeah.
That was to stop
all the knock‐offs.
‐Yeah.
‐Correct.
‐So you have spent,
obviously,
a lot of money on marketing.
How much money and what was
the form of marketing?
Facebook
is our primary channel.
It's where we spend more than
90% of our revenue dollars.
‐And how much did you spend?
‐How much did you spend?
About $3 million
on Facebook.
And then ‐‐
Probably closer to $4 million.
‐Really?
‐Closer ‐‐
Closer to $4 million.
‐Yeah.
‐$4 million on Facebook ads?
Aren't you better going off
to influencers?
Facebook has always
performed for us.
We can criticize
your customer acquisition
and your marketing spend ‐‐
I get it.
What I'm struggling with is,
what's this $20 million B. S.?
We've had a discussion
with a‐an investment bank
that specializes
in the drinkware space,
and this type of product,
when you get to the point
where it's brand,
which we're actively
building successfully ‐‐
And it's ‐‐
What did they value it at?
Four times gross
is what they sold ‐‐
‐Four times gross revenue?
‐Four times gross?
‐Correct.
But they're not willing
to write a check.
Look, you've done a great job,
but it's just about valuation
at this point.
We're so far apart.
Our ‐‐ Our whole
point of doing this
is to build and continue
to build a durable brand.
Let me pitch you guys.
I got a deal for you.
Ready?
Buckle your chin strap.
I have $9 million in sales.
At the end of all that,
I have $400,000 in my pocket.
I have $3 million
in marketing costs,
and I have $500,000
in legal fees.
Why would you
want to invest with me?
Well, the legal fees
were built last year on ‐‐
I'm out.
I mean, it just makes no sense.
Look, this is what I call
a schmutz deal, right?
Even if you guys hit
on all cylinders,
where's the upside for us?
So, you sell for $20 million,
we break even.
You know, you sell
for $40 million, we double,
but it's still not a huge number
all things considered
relative to the risk.
You just didn't price it
in a way that accommodates
the risk/reward,
so for those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay.
Good luck, though.
Thank you.
All right, you want
my million bucks
to help you launch into retail.
It's not just money.
It's also the strategic
partnership.
I‐I'm struggling with how
to structure this thing,
'cause I‐I love revenue.
I really do.
I love cash flow.
These things ‐‐
And royalties.
And I love royalties, too.
How about this deal?
I give you $250,000 for 10% and
$750,000 as a line of credit,
which is basically
factoring at 11%.
Then you have a Shark.
That's true.
And I don't feel like a schmuck
paying for ridiculous valuation.
Frankly, you need capital.
Kevin, I'm ‐‐ Let me give them,
uh, an offer here.
So you said $250,000
for 10%.
I'm gonna give you
$500,000 for 20%.
We'll do it together.
We'll give you another $500,000
at the 11%,
three years, that's convertible,
at the same valuation.
Yeah, I'm interested
in that deal.
Get two Sharks,
there's your million bucks.
You don't look excited.
Going from being willing
to sell 5%,
which is certainly
negotiable to an extent,
to 20% is ‐‐
is beyond what we're ‐‐
where we're
willing to go.
Were you willing to go 10%?
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Alex and Kevin have offered
Matt and Adam $500,000
plus a $500,000 line
of credit for a 20% stake
in their insulated
bottle holder,
BottleKeeper, but Lori
also seems interested.
Do you have an offer?
♪♪
I would do ‐‐
Best deal to do is...
[ Indistinct whispering ]
Corcoran: Would you
speak louder, Mark?
That was interesting.
I'm gonna give you
a million dollars,
with a $3‐per‐unit royalty
until I get double
my money back, and...
‐Wow. Geez.
‐Ugh.
...I would wind up with 3%
of the company.
The problem is, we're already
facing cash crunches.
Royalty is good here
because you're asking
for a lot of money.
Okay, how about ‐‐
So a million dollars ‐‐
Are you countering who?
We're countering Lori.
A million dollars for 3%
and a dollar per unit until
you get $1.5 million back.
♪♪
If you make it ‐‐
If you stay at the 5%,
I'll do that deal.
No! Make it...
Wait a minute, Mark ‐‐
...$1.50.
Hey, you know what?
If you think he's gonna do
better for you
in all those arenas...
Well, what did you
say the amount ‐‐
What was the amount?
...then do a deal with him.
What was the royalty?
We're just trying to understand
what's going on.
What was the amount back
for royalty that you said?
$1.50.
Okay, for the 3%, you'll
get $1.5 million back.
Is there an opportunity here
for you two
to team up in
a structured deal like them?
For either of you two
to work together.
Meaning what?
Meaning we'll take ‐‐
How about this?
For...
Let's go 5%
instead of the 3%
for total?
[ Indistinct whispering ]
It has to be $2.
If you guys would be interested
at going in together,
we'll give 5%
instead of the 3%,
and it would be $1.50 per unit
until you both get ‐‐
until you get
the $1.5 million back.
We'll do the same deal
for a buck and ‐‐
$2, and it's done.
No, no, no. No.
Instead of $2, $1.50,
but 200%.
♪♪
That's good, too.
It's a deal.
Welcome to the
Warm Beer Haters club.
Oh, my God. And that's what
you get for giving beers.
Cuban: Why is it
that I always drink myself
into spending
a million dollars?
‐I love it.
‐That's beautiful.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Congratulations.
‐This is gonna be fun.
‐Yeah, we'll have a lot of fun.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Good luck.
Callinan: Offers start coming,
and then complicated offers.
It was a lot more of an intense
negotiation than I expected.
Sure. It's the Shark Tank,
right?
Congrats.
Your first royalty deal.
No, not my first.
You've learned from the master.
If the investment goes bad,
you can always drink it away.
‐Cheers.
♪♪
Ahh.
Oh, my God, that's delicious.
Incredible.
I don't think
I've ever needed a beer
more than right then.
[ Clicks tongue ]
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 9,
Chris Gronkowski landed a deal
with Alex Rodriguez
and Mark Cuban
for his protein drink shaker
and cooler Ice Shaker.
Mark,
if you're interested,
I think we can bring
a lot to this business.
Oh, no question.
Let's see what he's up to now.
Gronkowski: When I first pitched
on "Shark Tank,"
Ice Shaker had $80,000
in sales in the first
six months of business.
It's been less than a year,
and we've done
over $3 million in sales.
So, I've seen the numbers.
Show me the products.
Rodriguez: Mark and I invested
in Ice Shaker both because
it had a great entrepreneur
running it in Chris,
but with me, I'm involved
in over 1,000 gyms
both domestically
and internationally,
so it's gonna be
a great addition to us.
You haven't done anything
in retail,
and that's what
we're gonna do next.
Gronkowski: Mark and Alex
are the perfect Sharks for me.
They're in the fitness industry,
so they get it.
Mark and his team have helped
negotiate contracts
with companies like GNC.
We're currently in 35 locations
and are looking to expand
into 1,100 locations soon.
Immediately after "Shark Tank,"
Alex brought Ice Shaker
into his local UFC gym in Miami
as a test, and so far,
it's been a huge hit.
How many people here
have heard of Ice Shaker?
[ Cheering ]
It's done so well,
we're now gonna roll it out
to 150 UFC gyms
across the country.
It's such a big deal to have the
UFC family endorse Ice Shaker.
This relationship
and how we are gonna scale it
is gonna be a grand slam.
Gronkowski: "Shark Tank"
has been amazing.
There's nothing else
that can take you
from a part‐time job
into this huge moneymaking
machine in less than one year.
As a Gronkowski,
I feel like a beast right now.
I can't wait to tell my bros.
There's only one thing
left to do.
Aah!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a treat
that capitalizes
on the keto diet craze.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Kristoffer.
And I'm Victor, and we are
the founders of Nui!
Nui!
Where we make saying "no"
to sugar ridiculously easy,
tasty, and fun.
And today we are seeking
$300,000 for 10% of our company.
So, a couple years ago,
our lives were changed forever.
Victor and I
cut out the sugar
and went on a low‐carb
ketogenic diet,
and it was amazing.
I stopped napping.
And I lost over 40 pounds.
We felt invincible ‐‐
that is,
until we had to face
our sugar cravings.
Sugar was everywhere.
It was in donuts, in brownies,
and even
in our biggest weakness...
Both: Cookies!
So instead of caving in,
we go to my mom's kitchen,
and with no baking experience,
created Nui,
a super‐yummy cookie
with only one gram of sugar.
Nui cookies are a delicious
and nutritious harmony
of almonds and good fats,
like coconut oil
and grass‐fed butter.
You can eat this whole box
of Nui cookies
and still consume less sugar
than one traditional cookie.
Wow.
We use a proprietary blend
of natural sweeteners
that taste just like sugar,
but without all
the sugary consequences.
So, Sharks, will you help us
make the world...
Both:
A butter place?
‐Can we taste it?
‐Of course, yeah.
Yes. Absolutely.
That's how we bribe you.
‐Bring on the Nui.
‐Yeah.
This is for you, Mark.
Thanks, Victor.
That's for you, Lori.
Thank you.
And for you,
Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome.
‐Oh.
‐Ooh, it looks good.
‐Appreciate it.
‐Yes.
‐Mm, smells great.
‐Not bad.
Delicious.
How many carbs
in this cookie?
There are two grams
of net carbs per cookie.
Wow.
What am I eating here? Sand?
[ Laughter ]
So, we use almond flour,
and we sweeten it
with natural sweeteners, uh,
monk fruit and erythritol.
How many calories in this?
If it's just one cookie
individual,
I'd say
about 140 calories.
Any protein in here?
Uh, six grams of protein
per serving.
Nice.
We have a lot of traction.
Over the last 12 months,
we have sold $1.1 million
worth of cookies.
‐Whoa.
‐Good for you guys.
How? How did you find
your customers?
So, we reached out
on social media to people
that were influential
in the ketogenic space,
which is growing
very rapidly.
Can we get a little bit
about both of your backgrounds?
Yeah, so, uh, my parents
immigrated here from Mexico,
and I feel like I've been
an entrepreneur my whole life.
In kindergarten,
I bought big bags of candy.
I sold the individual pieces
door‐to‐door
as a way to make money.
In junior high, I started
a lawn‐mowing company.
I became the first
person in my family to
ever graduate from college.
Good for you.
So, my parents came here
from the Philippines,
and I remember my dad
used to work four jobs
just to put food on the table.
Wow.
And he really taught me
what hard work really means.
And my mom,
she used to tell me,
"If you don't like something,
don't complain.
Change it."
So, guys, those sales numbers
are impressive.
You gonna tell us
how you did it?
Yeah, so, it's all been
through our website.
We're not even on Amazon yet.
So we're not even on Amazon yet,
which we are launching
this month,
and we're expecting our sales
to double or triple.
Are you making these
in a commercial kitchen now?
We've moved to a co‐packer
recently.
Finally.
Part of the challenge this year
has been being
able to meet the demand.
We sold $630,000
year to date.
Half of those six months,
we have been sold out.
Can you give us
the numbers on it?
So, we sell them
for $29.95 ‐‐
Can we get a couple
of boxes to look at?
‐Yeah.
‐Yeah, thanks.
We sell them for $29.95
plus $4.95 shipping.
Wow, expensive.
Um...
Cuban:
For how many cookies?
Each box has 10 packs.
Each pack has 2 cookies.
So 20 cookies.
So it's 20 cookies.
What are the margins on this?
What do you make them for?
Depending on the flavor,
between $11 and $13.
That's the best price
that you could get it down to?
O‐Our goal this year is
to get to 75% gross margin.
Part of it is, we're looking
to hire someone in operations
that has great relationships
with supply partners
as well as, uh,
manufacturing partners.
Guys, can you get this down
to 6 bucks in cost?
That's the goal.
So, yeah.
'Cause you can't go into retail
if ‐‐ if you're spending
more than $6 making this.
Yes.
And one of our challenges
has been cash
to be able to buy inventory
to be able to buy at the volume
needed to be able to
reduce the cost.
Over the last 12 months,
tell me how much you've netted.
Profit.
Our net, if we're counting
the last 12 months, is $35,000.
O'Leary: What is your
average cost, $12.50?
Yeah.
Right.
So you're basically making
about 11% of profit.
But our customer
lifetime value is, uh ‐‐
‐Do they reorder?
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Yes, they do.
What ‐‐ What evidence
do you have of that?
Uh, we have data,
'cause it's all e‐commerce.
Guys, I‐I'm gonna
clear the deck,
because one of my companies,
Alyssa's Healthy Cookies,
which is low calorie,
low net carbs.
I don't know that we compete
or not compete,
but it's just not a deal
I can do,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Totally understand that.
Guys, I like
what you're doing.
I just can't get close
to your valuation.
So I will respectfully go out.
Thank you.
Appreciate your time.
So, I happen to know a woman
that loves cookies,
and I mean loves.
Jennifer eats a cookie every
night before she goes to bed,
but I‐I‐I'm trying to get,
still,
into this valuation, Kevin.
‐It's incredible.
‐I wonder how you get there.
Here's the solution.
'Cause I want to ‐‐
Yeah, tell me, Kevin.
Here's the solution.
Rather than fight
about valuation,
'cause you're gonna have
a hell of a fight,
I'll make you the same offer
I made Wicked Good Cupcakes
when they stood
exactly where you were,
and they have
become multimillionaires.
Here's how it works.
It's a dollar a sale ‐‐
that's the royalty on it ‐‐
until I get my $300,000 back,
then it drops to 45 cents
in perpetuity,
and I get 2.5% equity just to be
a partner and stay motivated.
I'll never pay you
a $3 million valuation now,
nor will any other Shark,
but it doesn't mean
you don't have a great business.
That's the solution.
Align our interests.
There's an offer.
We appreciate the offer.
We'd like to respect
the other folks, as well.
I'll give you an offer.
I'll give you the $300,000.
$150,000 in cash,
$150,000 in a credit line.
I want 50 cents for each box
of cookies you sell,
and I want 15% equity.
Ouch!
This is a deal that I would
really be excited about.
♪♪
So, I connect with both
your stories,
coming from immigrant parents,
as well.
I can really appreciate
what really having a P. H. D.
is all about ‐‐
the poor, hungry, and driven ‐‐
and I really feel
that both of you have that.
So here's my offer.
$300,000 for 25%.
Ouch.
But we are gonna grow you
to a company that you're gonna
be very proud of very soon.
But it's 25%.
I would ask him
a few questions on that.
What do you mean you're gonna
help me scale it?
I would get the specifics.
Yeah.
I mean, we would love to ‐‐
Is ‐‐ Is Barbara your attorney?
No, I'm just saying, these kids
are entitled to an explanation.
Yeah, we would love to hear
how that would work,
'cause 25% is a lot.
You still own 75%
after this deal, right?
What you want to do is grow
the large pizza
and get a nice piece of it.
‐All right, guys, look.
25% is crazy.
I'm asking for 2.5% equity.
I'm gonna give you
massive social.
I'm already in this space
like crazy,
and 2.5% equity is just there
so that when you exit,
I get a tip.
But 25%, that's crazy.
For 2.5%, you won't be
able to get him on the phone.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Kristoffer and Victor
have three offers
on the table
for their cookie company, Nui.
Kevin offered $300,000
for a 2.5% stake
with a dollar royalty,
which reduces to 45 cents,
Barbara offered $150,000
plus a $150,000 line of credit
for 15% and a 50‐cent royalty,
while Alex offered $300,000
for 25%.
I've been looking at the space
of cookies
now for a while.
Okay.
And it's something
that we've been wanting
to take wide really quickly,
and we're thinking
direct‐to‐consumer
is the best process.
I get two young entrepreneurs
I believe in,
but more importantly
is what you guys can inherit
and the position
I'm gonna put you in.
♪♪
Would you come down
to 20%
with an opportunity
for a line of credit?
'Cause we know that,
as we scale,
we're gonna need, uh, some
additional funds for cash flow.
Guys, 25% is the best
deal that you'll ever cut.
Don't do that.
That's way too much equity.
Way too much.
It's crazy.
[ Indistinct whispering ]
We just don't know
how we could do 25%.
♪♪
You've got to decide, kids.
Do you think cash flow?
Um...
Barbara, would you be
able to do $300,000 cash
with a line of credit
for 15%?
No, it's $150,000
and $150,000.
You understand that there's
a 50‐cent royalty on that.
50 cents is nothing.
You're giving up ‐‐
Are you changing yours?
Well, I'm just pointing out.
He's 45 cents.
‐That's 5 cents difference.
‐You guys realize ‐‐ You guys
realize you're arguing ‐‐
O'Leary: But I don't
have 15% equity.
You weren't willing
to give up equity,
but you're arguing about
this other form of payment
that will probably
end up costing you
more than the equity
would have cost you.
I‐I'm just gonna say one more
thing, 'cause I like you.
Sometimes
you have to understand
when the opportunity
of a lifetime is hitting you,
and when
you're cashing a check
of several hundred
million dollars,
you're not gonna worry
about the 5% or the 10%.
[ Laughs ]
And I'll tell you
what I'll do.
22.5% ‐‐
I'll split the baby with you ‐‐
and I get a $1 royalty
instead of a 50‐cent.
You guys keep on
going backwards.
O'Leary: That's crazy.
Could we go back
to the initial deal?
If you're willing to do the 25%
original deal, we're in.
♪♪
‐We got a deal.
‐Good move.
‐There you go.
‐All right.
‐Talk about full circle.
‐We're in business.
‐We're gonna have some fun.
‐Yeah.
‐Team hug.
‐Yeah!
Good job.
All right, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐I'll be a customer.
‐Yes.
‐[ Laughs ]
Are you serious, man?!
[ Laughs ]
It was worth giving up
more equity for ARod, one,
because he connects
with our story,
and, two, because we know
there's a bigger pie out there.
♪♪